selon les contrôleurs routiers de la saq
le conducteur de ce camion a une vision
très limité de son entourage en raison
de ce que l'on appelle les angles morts
nous avons eu l'occasion de monter à
bord de ce poids lourd lors d'une
activité de sensibilisation portant
justement sur les angles morts 69 % mais
les gens ne savent pas où sont ces gens
ne mangent ni lord masson c'est
inquiétant voici donc les fameuses
humblement des véhicules lourds c'est en
rouge sur cette maquette et on voit
c'est beaucoup plus grand que l'on pense
ce qui veut dire que le conducteur ne
vois pas par exemple cette poussette à
l'avant du camion ni ce cycliste sur le
côté plusieurs citoyens se sont prêtés à
l'exercice à la van vous présente ma de
véhicules il ya une poussette pour enfin
ne vous la voyez pas
voyez pour le véhicule qui n'avait
imaginé cyclistes piétons des enfants
c'est la rentrée scolaire et c'est le
côté avant droit du camion qui le moins
visible pour le conducteur alors voici
un conseil précieux est ce que je vois
les yeux du conducteur donc si vous les
voyez vous êtes au bon endroit où vous
les voyez pas vous êtes en danger dans
son engagement et vous devez vous
déplacer pour et par sécurité selon la
société de l'assurance automobile du
québec
les véhicules lourds sont impliqués dans
23 % des accidents mortels avec piéton
et 28 % des accidents mortels avec
cyclistes à montréal seulement
maintenant selon le spvm il y a eu la
dernier huit personnes qui ont été tuées
dans une collision impliquant un camion
lourd qu'à chaque formule également deux
autres conseils porté attention au tri
gnata des véhicules aux intersections et
surtout soyez visible à portant des
vêtements voyants
issigeac bissonnet radio canada montréal